duh
she's the bad guy duh Victoria and David
Beckham's eight-year-old daughter Harper
went all out Billy Eilish for Halloween
really really cool on Thursday the proud
parents shared these spooky family pics
to Instagram yep that's a Romeo Brooklyn
and Harper posing it up with their
famous dad with the boys you know where
there's a lot of energy a lot of energy
24 hours you know 24/7 it's kind of full
of energy but then you know a little
girl comes into the mix and you know she
sweetens the whole house up and it's
it's amazing even their dog got in on
the holiday spirit rocking a Batman suit
but let's be honest
Harper definitely stole the show rockin
Billy's signature look baggy clothes
white sneakers and blue hair how in
general would you describe your style I
like to be judged so I wanna I want to
see heads look up Toria shared this pic
of her little girl complete with those
black tears a la Billie's when the
party's over music video
[Music]
Victoria captioned the shot quote Harper
seven loves Billy Eilish
and a heavy eye and guys she was not
kidding
not only did Harper help her big brother
get a killer Halloween smokey eye but
she also helped David achieve a heavy
eye using her mom's makeup did you hear
that that's the sound of women all over
the world
booing and eyeing I mean come on she
does to try on my clothes she also loves
makeup you know she is very feminine
yeah but she's also a bit of a tomboy as
well so she likes to run around the
garden with David and the boys playing
football but she can walk better in a
pair of heels than most grown women let
me tell you the former soccer pro also
revealed that one of the families
trick-or-treating stops was to Justin
and Haley Bieber's house how Hollywood
is that Justin shared this pic to his
insta story explaining that they weren't
just going to give away your
run-of-the-mill candy for Halloween they
were handing out snow cones people
romeow later shared this snap with his
little sister thanking the Bieber's for
the icy treat as for Harper
well David said the snow cone was the
highlight of her night I have no power
with that little girl no power
whatsoever you know I I love all my
children of course equally but you know
the boys are boys you know they kind of
get on with everything but you know I
I'm probably stricter with the boys and
I then I'm definitely stricter with the
boys and I am Harper which gets me in
trouble with my wife of course but like
I say I have no power with with when she
asked for something can't say no and the
award for hottest sweetest dad on the
planet goes to David Beckham of course
ET will be here to bring you all of
David's cute dad moments so make sure to
keep it locked right here until next
time I'm Hallie Stephens bye for now
[Music]